تبادل الاتهامات مستمر موضوع عده اشهر بين
موسكو وكيف بقصف محطه النوويه التي تسيطر
عليها القوه الروسيه والقريبه من جبهه
القتال الجيش الروسي قال لان كيف اطلقت
يوم السبت والاحد نحو 20 قذيفه من العيار
الثقيل على المحطه
كارثه في محطه زبريجيا ففي التاسعه عشر من
تشرين الثاني نوفمبر اطلقت مدفعيه القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه 11 قذيفه مدفعيه من
العيار الثقيل على الاراضي المحطه في صباح
يوم 20 نوفمبر اطلقت القوات الاوكرانيه
النار مرتين على اراضي محطه الطاقه
النوويه
الاشعاع في المحطه الطبيعيه
اتهمت وكاله الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه
روسيه بقصف منطقه المحطه ان القوات
الروسيه تعرض العالم باسره للخطر صباح ال
20 من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر ونتيجه للقذف
الروسي سجلت 12 ضربه على الاقل في موقع
محطه
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه فوسطت الاخبار
الوارده من زبرجيا من مزعجه
وراء هذا يجب ان يتوقف على الفور انتم
تلعبون بالنار وتحتل القوه الروسيه التي
بدات غزوها لاوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين
من شباط فبراير من طاقه محطه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه وسبق ان قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين انه ضم المحطه واربعه
مناطق اوكرانيه